Effectiveness in high stakes situations
often boils down to expert teaming and
communication.
Yet many teams missed the mark and
perform sub optimally.
Hello, I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to think fast talk smart,
the podcast.
Today, I am thrilled to speak with Sarah
Singer, who is a professor of medicine
at Stanford School of Medicine and
a professor by courtesy at the GSB.
Sarah teaches the popular course leading
and managing health care organizations,
innovation and
collaboration in high stakes savings.
Her research focuses on measuring and
improving organizational culture,
learning, teamwork,
patient safety, integrated patient
care and culture of health.
Welcome, Sarah, thanks for being here.
>> Thanks for having me,
I'm excited to speak with you.
>> Great, let's get started.
Your research addresses the impact of
organizational culture in learning on
teamwork.
Can you share some insights into what
makes for high functioning teams?
>> When I try to boil the lessons down I
say that high performing teams require
cultures with three key characteristics.
So they need to be team oriented,
learning oriented, and systems oriented.
By that, I mean first a team oriented
culture suggests that leaders need to
create conditions that support teamwork,
including strategies that
overcome professional silos and
hierarchies which you find in spades and
healthcare organizations.
So for example, by establishing
clear roles and responsibilities and
making sure that people have an understand
the shared goals of the group, and
supportive practices like offering
team time so people can work together.
The second key characteristic is a
learning culture, where team members learn
from mistakes and experimentation so they
can adapt and change and innovate all key
factors for not just healthcare settings,
but lots of organizational settings.
Learning requires leadership that
reinforces learning a supportive
environment, including especially
psychological safety, but
also an appreciation for differences.
When you're working with people of
lots of different backgrounds and
openness to new ideas, these environments
need setting aside time for reflection.
And a learning environment also
requires learning practices and
processes that promote training,
knowledge acquisition,
performance monitoring in order to
facilitate learning in the team.
And that third key characteristics
was a systems oriented culture.
And by systems orientation,
I mean an orientation that keeps
people focus on whole systems.
And addresses problems across conditions
and across units and over time, so
that we overcome fragmentation and
we integrate across boundaries in order I
think of the systems around the patient.
So we're caring for the whole patients.
So there's a lot underlying these insights
but these are some of the essentials for
high performing teams.
>> Wow, so it really sounds
like it's about taking time to
define clear responsibilities
set up support in time for
reflection and really look beyond
your specific focus or silo.
I often think it's about people process
and infrastructure and it sounds like all
three of those play out to helping
high functioning teams be successful.
>> Absolutely especially in the
accomplishment of what I was describing is
that learning oriented culture,
you need the leadership,
you need the environment, and
you need those processes and practices.
And all of them need to be aligned
in a way that supports people's
willingness to speak up, to discuss
mistakes, to raise questions, so
that there is learning that occurs.
And that kind of open
communication is essential.
>> Two decades ago before returning
to academics, I ran learning and
development groups for
high tech companies and
I know that you've done
some research in that area.
For example, you looked at how
people learn new tools and
techniques when the situation changes and
existing expertise is no longer as useful.
Can you share what you found and what
lessons we can take away when it comes to
learning new skills for ourselves?
>> Sure, so this is recent research that
I did with Kate Kellogg from MIT where we
studied managers approaches to dealing
with this challenge of teaching new tools
and techniques.
And in this case we work with a large
healthcare system that wanted to introduce
a series of new processes.
So for example, standard patient rooming
was one of the processes and historically
the process of bringing a patient into
an exam room was just all over the map.
And the organization wanted
everyone to do it the same way and
to document it in the electronic
medical record the same way so
that they could bill more accurately for
it.
Another kind of standard process that they
were trying to implement were standards or
standard processes, standard timeframes
and documentation requirements for
following up with a patient who
visited the emergency department or
had been discharged from a hospital.
So all key things that organizations
needed to do more consistently in
the your era of electronic records.
So the managers in this case, recognized
that the newer and often younger workers
were more agile learners and
less committed to the status quo.
But the problem was that they were also
junior to the workers who had long tenure
there as the more senior
workers considered those more
junior workers as illegitimate
in the trainer role.
So in those units where managers assigned
the new workers to be the trainers,
there was a strong backlash and
the new processes were taken
up by the workers generally.
But in a few of the units what we saw is
that the managers rotated the trainer role
giving everybody a chance
to be the trainer.
And when the managers offered the promise
of this call of status mobility,
the senior worker trainees were willing
to learn from the junior trainers because
they knew that they would have the turn
to be the trainers and themselves later.
So this trainee status mobility,
we described as a mechanism that managers
can use when they need to teach
more tenured workers new skills.
>> Wow, and so that goes back to that
point of psychological safety that
you also mentioned earlier.
And that's a topic that's come
up before on this podcast.
So By helping people
feel more comfortable,
you're actually allowing them to learn and
grow.
>> Absolutely.
And I'm not surprised that psychological
safety has come up before on this
podcast because it is so critical for
the kind of learning that needs to happen
on any team that wants to adapt or
change or innovate.
So making people feel comfortable,
to be a learner at any state,
leaders need to learn all the time too.
And so making people comfortable and
confident that they can reach out with
questions or raise concerns and to
just be a learner is something that every
team needs in order to be successful.
>> So true, and I'm hoping that this
actual podcast serves some of that need to
help people learn more.
Let me ask another question about
another one of your projects.
In that project you noted that
high functioning healthcare teams
simultaneously focus on functional and
cultural change.
Can you define these two types of change
and share why addressing both is so
helpful to teams?
>> Yes certainly, so in this project
I studied primary care practices
working to transform the way
they delivered care.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Moving from doctors is the focus of
the work to team based care where doctors
work with a medical assistant a nurse
maybe a social worker and others to dress.
The whole holistic needs of the patients.
So our question was, what made some
practices more successful than others at
making this transition to team based care?
And what we found was that
the teams use different approaches.
So one form of approach was
a functional approach and
the other was a cultural approach.
And so these are sort of the way
that primary care practices
approached effecting change.
And by the functional approach we mean
an approach that focused on the practical
operational aspects of teaming things
like making sure that there was
clear role definition,
supportive structures and
ensuring shared access to clinical
data all critically important.
But that the cultural approach,
in contrast was an approach that
addressed the more normative and
relational aspects of teaming including
things like making sure that,
the hierarchy was flattened sufficiently
so that everybody felt like they could
provide some leadership and that there was
openness to experimentation on the team.
What we found was that the groups that
pursued one or the other didn't do as well
as the groups that pursued both,
that these were mutually reinforcing.
So for example, to successfully, establish
new roles, which was a functional goal.
That required sharing authority and
flattening traditional hierarchies,
which were both critical
aspects of culture.
And there was also this recursive
relationship between the two approaches in
that, the cultural changes created
an environment that were conducive to
the functional change and
that functional changes then,
in return supported the systems for
cultural changes.
So, by undertaking both simultaneously,
a practice site could create a positive
upward spiral that just got them better
and better at making the change.
So primary care practices that prioritize
both types of change processes and
pursued them simultaneously
were the most effective.
>> Wow I can see how that could help,
not just in primary care, but
in all organizations.
And in my mind, as you were describing it,
I don't know why this happened, but
I flashed to a yin yang symbol where
both parts blend together to bring out
the whole.
And it sounds like both a functional and
cultural approach are really
critical to being successful.
Now you know Sarah that this podcast
really focuses on communication.
So I have to ask you what role does
communication play in effective teamwork
and are there any best practices that you
suggest that can help all of us be more
effective in our teaming.
>> Absolutely,
communication plays a critical role,
especially in situations that are
stressful where people are under duress.
So think about the critical
moments in a surgical case, or
when a patient is experiencing
a cardiac arrest.
There are all sorts of critical moments
in healthcare where communication is key.
One best practice, for example, that we
advocate is closed loop communication.
Where one person says something and
another person repeats it back just to
make sure that they've gotten
the information correct.
So you say, we're ready for bypass and
the person who responds I'm
putting the patient on bypass.
Administer 10 cc of X Medication I'm
administering 10 ccs of X communication
just to make sure that that communication
is received in the way it was intended.
Another example is restructured forms of
communication and there are lots of them.
I spent a tremendous amount of time trying
to promote the use of surgical checklists,
which have been made famous by Atul
Gawande, who is a colleague of mine from
Harvard and
we work together on trying to spread this.
And I was responsible for the evaluation
of the implementation of that work.
But the basic idea is that
misunderstandings are possible and
especially where there is hierarchy
information doesn't often transmit.
And so making sure that you have
information kind of listed out
that you know you need to review and
that encourages not just
kind of the checks of the things that
you need to make sure that happen,
but also to prompt discussion
including an important
prompt that says,
I can't do this case alone.
I need you to speak up.
What if you see a problem so
extending that invitation and
creating the psychological
safety in the space.
Those forms of structured communication so
that it happens reliably every
time can be a critically helpful.
>> So much in what you just said.
So the first part about inviting in
almost requiring that instant response
increases what I call the F word of
communication and that is fidelity.
The accuracy and
clarity by building in that repetition.
You actually confirm that the other person
heard what you were saying there's In
a very simplistic model of communication
called the transactional model where
a sender sends a message to
a receiver who gives feedback.
And insisting on that
external verbal response,
you really do highlight fidelity and
reduce the noise that can get in the way.
And the point of checklists and
having as part of those checklists,
the structure the outline having part of
it that It demands that others involve and
collaborate.
I think it's so important we see in best
practices around how people actually meet.
So teaming often occurs in meetings.
And having those explicit
rules that everybody sees and
you go through those steps can be
very helpful to being effective,
efficient and
making sure that you achieve the goal.
So really helpful ideas for
communication there.
So I'm wondering if you have any last
thoughts or best practices that you'd like
to share with us on how we can be
better in the teams we participate in?
>> Let's see, so I can think of a couple.
>> Sure.
>> I guess one is to make sure that
the work that you are asking a team to
do actually requires a team to do it.
We forget that lots of work doesn't
actually benefit from teams.
If a work is interdependent then of course
it benefits from a team but if it's not
if individuals can work independently then
I say let the individuals do the work.
And avoid all the challenges
associated with teamwork and
the requirements of communication
because that's really hard.
And there are all sorts of ways in which
we are, we fail to communicate and so
we suffer those process losses and
teams don't necessarily do better than
than individuals so
I say make sure the work requires a team.
And then secondly I'd say when work
does require a team make sure everybody
fully understands, and is on board with
what the team needs to accomplish.
So when they are, they're more
likely to do the right things and
sometimes they'll do amazing things.
A very small example of this that
made me think of it is, yesterday,
I met with my research grant manager
to discuss the budget I was pulling
together for a new research
study that I'm proposing and I,
I said at the end we were
pulling things together.
I said, so do you have any
questions about the project itself?
And I realized that they knew
nothing about the project.
And so I explained the project, and
then they poured out with suggestions for
how to revise the budget to make it more
appropriate so that the funder would look
at it and say no, they've really given
this some thought it was so helpful to me.
And I learned that lesson over and
over again.
Everybody on the team has something to
contribute, and they can only contribute
it if they are on board with what
the team is trying to accomplish.
Especially the people
who are lower status and
we don't necessarily you
know have presidents in
all of the meetings they're important too
>> Absolutely that's a double A answer you
first need to make sure me that
teaming is appropriate and
then you need to make sure
that everybody's aligned So
the the appropriateness of meeting and
working in teams is the first question and
then you have to make sure
that everybody's aligned.
So thank you for that.
>> Of that.
>> So before we end, I like to ask
everybody the same three questions.
Are you up for answering them?
>> So I'll try.
>> All right, question number one.
If you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be?
>> Inspire change by
telling great stories.
>> I love that so
I like the inspiration part of that and
we've certainly heard across the many
podcasts the value that story has.
Bullet points lists that's hard for
us to understand and
take with us but
a good story is something that sticks.
So thank you for reminding about
us how a story can inspire.
>> I have to remind myself
of that all the time.
>> Right, exactly.
So question number two, who is
a communicator that you admire and why?
>> Nick Kristof and maybe because I was
thinking of the New York Times, but I
really admire the way he tells stories of
real people experiencing real suffering.
He clearly believes we need to hear these
stories in order to affect change and
I think he's brave at
hearing the hard things.
I think it's not easy to hear them and
to bring them to light and
share them with other people
in the way that he does.
I find that really tough and admirable.
>> What are the three first
ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe?
>> I have some fear trepidation to speak
this to someone who teaches a course in
strategic communication, but
I'll give it a shot though.
So the ones for
me I think are a message and
important message that you find
meaningful that you want to convey.
And the second is a connection, so
thinking about how does your message
relate to the people that
you're trying to reach?
And the third,
as we've been talking about,
is a story that moves people to agree or
to action.
So, climate change is a classic
example of this reform advocates first
talked about polar bears losing their
ice and it was less compelling.
Then the kind of message that
you're hearing now, which is about,
this is critical for the survival of
your children and your grandchildren and
we need to do something about it.
And the most compelling storyteller I
know in this genre is David Attenborough.
The one I like most recently was
a show called A Life on Our Planet,
which if you haven't seen it you really
must but quintessential storyteller.
And in my field the really compelling
stories tend to be about opportunities for
teams to save lives, or little lives lost.
More often we hear about lives
loss because teams have failed.
And they're often about ways that leaders
failed to establish psychological safety
so teams don't achieve
their full potential or
about lack of reliably safe processes.
So cardiovascular surgeon who shuts
down a conversation in the surgical room
by berating his trainees and
people don't speak up and
something terrible
happens to their patient.
Or the primary care team that
fumbles positive test result and
doesn't act when they have
information that they should act on.
And they don't catch the patient's
colorectal cancer until it's
progressed beyond the possibility for
treatment.
So super sad stories that
are calls to action and
we use them because we need people
to make make processes better
make communication better for
patients going forward.
>> Well you had nothing to worry about
in terms of your strategic communication
abilities you those three
ingredients are absolutely critical.
And can definitely be helpful not just
in a healthcare setting but beyond.
So Sarah, thank you so much.
Your ideas and insights into teamwork and
training and communication
are incredibly useful and actionable.
I appreciate your time and your insight.
>> Thank you I appreciate having
the opportunity to speak with you today.
>> Thank you for
listening to Think Fast Talk Smart,
the podcast a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
To learn more, go to gsb.stanford.edu.
Please download other episodes
wherever you find your podcasts
[MUSIC]